la situación sanitaria en francia del
coi 19 está estabilizada desde diciembre
del año pasado hay 24.000 nuevos casos
diarios 500 decesos diarios en promedio
obviamente sin embargo en la población
hay un rumor de que va a haber un nuevo
confinamiento y esto porque el
presidente manuel macrón debe presidir
el próximo miércoles un tercer gabinete
sanitario desde que se inició la
pandemia y parece que el gobierno está
muy presionado sobre todo por los
científicos para decretar un nuevo
confinamiento ellos tienen miedo de las
nuevas variantes de ccoo y 19 sobre todo
de la británica y no quieren tener una
crisis sanitaria como la que está
viviendo el reino unido- pero el
gobierno está preocupado de la reacción
social que puede generar un nuevo
confinamiento y de la reacción económica
por lo mismo el ejecutivo está esperando
los resultados para ver qué efectos ha
tenido el toque de queda a las 6 de la
tarde que estamos viviendo en francia y
también para ver con qué rapidez se
contagia efectivamente en francia la
nueva cepa lo otro es que el ejecutivo
francés tiene seguro es que de hacer un
tercer confinamiento las
y seguirían abiertas